I just want to say something about why I do it
as an amsterdamer
no longer like to
to live in Amsterdam
let's know honestly
Amsterdam is simply no longer for the Amsterdamer
I have said before that 70% of my street exists
the experts who do not speak Dutch
the rest of the street are juppen
and then there is 1 very small part
with people already here
I think living for 30 years
because otherwise you will not get a house here
the greengrocer and the bakery I used to go to
those are now for jupte coffee shops
this is the carousel
the pancake restaurant where I grew up
literally that has to go now
the identity of the city is just being wiped out
after that they will also remove the ramparts
that is also something that simply belongs to Amsterdam
I understand they don't want crime there
I understand that
but then better maintain
because the reason they want to remove the fucking ramparts
is so that they are in all those properties
can do hip coffee shops
it has been like this for a long time
that I just don't feel anymore
like how I used to feel in my city
and I just think that's a real shame
and the real Amsterdamers
they have to flee the city
because it is simply too expensive for them
so uh yeah guys